Riley has just about had it she has
become an incredibly outspoken voice
against boys and girls swimming which
something 10 years ago we all know we
all would have agreed with here she is
at the Senate hearing and it's uh it's
rather extraordinary
in addition to being forced to give up
our Awards and our titles and our
opportunities
the NCAA forced me and my female submers
to swim to share a locker room with
Thomas
at six foot four 22 year old male
equipped with and exposing male
genitalia
let me be clear about this
we were not forewarned we would be
sharing a locker room
no one asked for our consent and we did
not give our consent
and I'll set the scene assuming locker
room is not a place of modesty you're
undressing you're fully exposed and we
were forced to take off our swimsuit in
front of a man who was doing the exact
same thing
if nothing else I truly hope how you can
see this is a violation of our right to
privacy and now some of us have felt
uncomfortable embarrassed and even
traumatized by this experience
I know that I don't speak for every
single person who competed against Leah
Thomas but I know I speak for many
because I saw the tears I saw the tears
from the 9th and 17th Place finishers
who missed out on being named an
All-American by one place and I can
attest to the extreme discomfort in the
locker room when you from these 18 to 22
year old girls when you turn around
and there's male eyes watching in that
same room and I can attest to The
Whispers And The grumbles of anger and
frustration from these girls who just
like myself had worked our entire lives
to get to this meet
and I can attest to the fact that around
the country these female athletes who
opposed the inclusion of Leah Thomas in
the women's divisions were threatened
intimidated in emotionally blackmailed
into silence and submission
you know that girl is a true hero you
know a hero is not necessarily somebody
who wants to be a hero from day one a
hero is someone who along the journey
something happens and then they choose
to walk into the fire and that's what
she is this is a girl who committed her
life to being the best swimmer she could
be happens to be a female so you compete
against other females do you think if
you would have asked Riley Gaines three
years ago would you like to be or do you
think one day you will be testifying in
front of the Senate because there will
be a guy in the locker room who will be
beating you and swimming she would say
you're completely insane everyone would
have said that was complete Insanity and
yet here she is fighting it and you know
what's happening to her right now the
mainstream media corporate press blah
blah blah she's now far right she's an
evil conservative she also happens to be
supporting Governor DeSantis for
president because he's actually fighting
against that stuff in Florida so you
know obviously she's very scary because
of that
[Music]
foreign